good morning millennials welcome back to
the morning toast happy friday
it's another beautiful day in new york
city even though the weather up had said
that we were going to have like some
rough weather at the end of this week
it's
gorgeous hey claude how you doing i'm
good i
still wouldn't know what the weather is
because i live in a bunker where i don't
open the shades and i like to keep it
that way
definitely has its you know moments
where it affects my mental health but
for the most part
i'm okay with it no it really is a
beautiful day beautiful blue sky
some clouds um yeah it was nice i opened
my shades every morning like
take a look at the weather and sitting
in my room all day like all i do is
stare out the window so the weather
actually
has an effect and when it's nice out it
means that i'm gonna go outside and do
something today and when it's raining it
means i'm not
so the weather i've really become
weather dependent which i've never been
that kind of girl
yeah it i mean i haven't been outside
yet but it seems like it's
like a stunning day to pre-order my
comedy special would you agree
oh my god yes it's the perfect weather
to pre-order a comedy special
yeah it's just like when you look
outside you can't help but think like
wow
i suddenly feel the urge to order a
comedy special on itunes
you just look outside and you're like oh
my gosh i need to laugh
is there a new comedy special that i
could pre-order on itunes
well jackie i'm so glad you asked there
is it's called claudia ashrae disgraced
queen
and it is available for pre-order on
itunes and i got a bunch of questions
about it and here
allow me to answer when it's released on
june 30th it will be available for
purchase in a few other platforms
such as amazon that of uh
a few others i don't remember the names
but um for the most part amazon and
itunes are the major platforms and i'm
just so grateful for everyone who tagged
me in their stories letting me know that
they pre-ordered it left a nice review
really made me feel good um i did leave
myself a review because at first there
were no reviews and i'm like i don't
want everyone to think i'm a loser
and i got to like number seven on itunes
which made me feel really good i'm like
how does everyone have thousands and i'm
on number seven on itunes with zero
reviews so i left myself a review
and um it didn't uh populate
and then there was one review and
someone left one review they were like
this special sucks i'm like you didn't
even see it yet so like you can't even
make that decision
so um thankfully the toasters came in
now i have like 30 reviews and that
makes me feel good
oh good i'm so excited that's like such
a great thing to have on the calendar
to be excited about because you know
there's not much that gets the juices
flowing these days
no there's not but we have that and
we'll always have that like once it's
out we will always have it especially if
you pre-order it on itunes because then
it's yours and you own it
the link is in my bio and instagram you
really can't miss it
um and i just would like to apologize to
you jackie and everyone listening to
this podcast for the next 30 days um
because i will speak of nothing else and
you're just gonna have to be okay with
that that's okay
i mean that's what we're here for to
hear what's on your mind and if that's
what's on your mind for 30 days then
so be it it is what it is i
said what i said and that's that on that
um my face is just getting crazier and
crazier in the queue because
of my lack of botox like i'm just making
faces that
i couldn't make before and i don't enjoy
it
i miss my forehead that doesn't move but
you know what the quarantine is actually
a great time to like
learn about your favorite bloggers and
like what their real hair color is and
you know how long their real eyelashes
are
and how long they're real mustaches and
i feel like it's really
um it's really like you know also like
what size their lips really are just
like things like that
and i feel like for the most part i look
aside from my forehead like
i look the same in quarantine yeah we
should check in
and all of our viewers should check in
on their friends with eyelash extensions
because they're not
doing well no they're really not doing
well and i feel like also quarantine has
been a great time for me to prove that
i'm a natural redhead
and that my lips are natural as well
i'm not convinced you're not no i look
how long my hair has gotten i blew out
my hair
i saw on your instagram story i'm like
disgustingly jealous um
i wouldn't know because i have not blown
my hair out i had like my hair's been in
a bun for the last two months and i
guess it's growing
but that did make me jealous of people
who have roots because they legit know
how much their hair has grown in
quarantine because you can just see it
that's true it's like a ruler yeah like
it's actually full of interesting
factoids
um all my knitting supplies arrived
yesterday so i have a feeling i'm about
to uh have one of the greatest weekends
of my life
oh that's nice you should get into this
um i'm okay i'm like all stocked up on
hobbies right now and this weekend i
have to read the new redheads book
because we're recording next week
this episode just snuck up on us um i'm
really excited to read this book i
haven't heard much about it
but um i haven't read since the last red
heads this is the first time that that's
happened to me so now i'm grateful for
the redheads because if it wasn't for
the podcast book club i wouldn't be
reading and
it's that's really the point of the book
club is to keep you reading in the queue
and like keep you
interested and having thoughtful
discussions and i'm really excited it's
always a great
series of days when we record the
redheads and then release it to the
redheads community
and it's confusing that that we call
ourselves the redheads and the fans are
the redheads and we're all just the
redheads and on the other side
but um it works yeah no you guys are
definitely having a profound effect on
me i read one book this week and i
started a second one
wow yeah so i don't know
things are changing you guys you never
know what's gonna happen one day you're
reading
the next day or not amen like
this week you've read more than me wow
that's crazy
you know what i feel is really um
important when it comes to books that
not a lot of people talk about
the font well on kindle you can choose a
custom font
but like i use the font that they give
me but you can change the size of it and
you can make it all your own which is
just another
reason why the kindle is everything yeah
and you know i have a lot of problems
with reading books like
when you're in the middle of a book a
book sits open perfectly equally which
is nice but if you're at the very
beginning or the very end like
the heavier side is always [ __ ] like
getting in your face
and i find myself like literally ripping
the book in half like bending it
backwards so hard just so it [ __ ]
stays open
i need this staples button kindle you
don't got that problem
for sure i don't read enough now well i
read once like i need to calm down but
i don't think i'm going to read enough
to warrant a kindle but
it's a nice activity and it's really
easy on the eyes like some of this tv
the blue light's killing my eyes
that's what i've been saying also a
kindly mention that someone should
invent is like
every time you want to get to a next
page on the kindle you need to tap the
screen
like if i just got into a cozy position
where my hands are like under the
blanket
that would mean i have to take my hand
out of the blanket every time i need to
turn the page
someone needs to invent a little clicker
that you can just hold in your hand and
just
click it and it will go to the next page
in the next page it's a small
issue but you know since we're out here
solving problems
i guess the assumption is though if
you're reading on the kindle one of your
hands is on it
no but like i i try to like let my
kindle stand
up against something like i'll use like
a pillow and lean it up so that
i don't have to hold it because i have
weak wrists um
and so if i could just get like a little
bluetooth clicker to tap from page to
page you know what i'm sure it exists
like it seems like
not a reinvention of the wheel um
so let me know and that's like a selfie
stick that's what they have
yes exactly like a selfie okay cool
cool well we have a great show for you
today before you embark on a fabulous
weekend if you're in a state that's
opening up and if you're like me
um before you embark on a weekend of
solitary confinement
i can't believe that there are people
like going to bars i'm so [ __ ]
jealous
so [ __ ] jealous let us out
i am so [ __ ] jealous i know it's just
so crazy like how each state
it's just a whole different world like
people are going free country
there are people in this country who are
going to dinner and drinks
and there are people in this country
like us who are going on our
60th day of quarantine we're already on
day
today sorry we started on march 13th may
15th so it was 62 on
march 3 on may 13 63
64th day and next week will be week
10. that's insane i'm in the prime
of lime i'm in the prime of my life i
want a [ __ ] party i want to blackout
i want to throw up at a club like i've
had enough
i've had a [ __ ] enough no i've had
enough he
liked the quarantine so i'm not sure
where i stand we did our part
we did our part let us out i want to get
tested for antibodies
you should actually like yeah you should
i just don't want to go to a like a a
doctor's office or
where there's like an urgent care
because i feel like maybe i'm gonna get
it there when like i should have just
stayed home
um i went to a city md last week and i
was the only person there
so i think you're fine okay i'll think
about yeah they said things were so
quiet they were thinking about closing
but then they got these antibodies and
now some people are coming in but like
i think there's this maybe in some
places it's super congested maybe on a
beautiful day at like high noon
um there's a line around the block but i
went on a day
i guess it was a little rainy maybe
that's why no one was there
yeah i mean but i've heard about a lot
of faulty
antibody tests i think tpg got like
three or something he got a false
negative then a false positive
i don't even know what he ended up with
yeah so from
what i've gathered there's an antibody
test that's like a finger prick and you
get your results
almost immediately or within a few hours
that one is
not to be fully believed the one that
they do at city md where they take a
vial of blood and it takes they send it
to a lab and it takes days for you to
get your results
i believe that's the most accurate one
and i haven't heard of anyone
getting a false positive or negative but
i also don't talk to that many people
but i also haven't read that in the news
did you faint because you donated blood
in high school and i remember seeing you
in the hi
in the hallways right after and you
legit looked to me your eyes rolled to
the back of your head and you fainted
no because a vial of blood is like this
much whereas when you donate
um blood like it's a bag bag
um literally never forget that like
you left so [ __ ] weak and you like
leaned on that on the wall
and you were right outside the nervous
nurse's office so i was like nurse nurse
and she came out with a bag um to for
you to vomit into
and the bag had a hole in the bottom so
i just threw up all over my lap
and that was the last time i donated
blood i guess i'm just not really a
candidate
i tried people can't handle it i um the
one time i went to donate blood i had
left the country like two months ago and
they said i couldn't
you tried any rules so many rules just
like let me help you know
yes i know well anyways that's the
latest on us
just eager to get back to life
you know and eager to dive in you know
not so eager but we have to recap real
housewives of new york and
let's just see what [ __ ] went on
today the stories are just getting
thinner and thinner
okay you know what here's like the let's
actually i'm sorry
without further ado it's time for the
fast five stories that you like kind of
should maybe need to know or if you want
to
before you wake up and take a bite out
of your morning toast
yeah that's true for sure um they they
might need to know
about these stories but they definitely
need to know about today's sponsor
story worth these days we can have many
ways of staying in touch with family
even when we can't visit them in person
which during the quarantine is a big
issue for a lot of people
being able to instantly check in with
family is great but sometimes we want to
bond in other more meaningful ways
thanks to story worth we're connecting
with loved ones everywhere and learning
family history we never knew about
story worth is a fun and meaningful way
to engage with family especially with
relatives you might not get to see often
this online service helps your loved
ones share stories through
thought-provoking questions about their
memories and personal thoughts
it's the gift of spending time together
wherever you live every week story worth
emails your family members different
story prompts
questions you never thought to ask like
what have been some of your life's
greatest surprises
what's one of the riskiest things you've
ever done reading the weekly stories is
fun and makes your family feel close
even though they're not together
after one year story worth will compile
every answered question and photo you
choose to include into a beautiful
keepsake book
that's shipped for free our family and
your family can treasure this book
forever
connect with family and discover untold
stories with story worth get started
right away without the need for shipping
by going to storyworth.com toast you can
get ten dollars off your first purchase
if you go to story worth
s-t-o-r-y w-o-r-t-h dot com
slash toast for ten dollars off that's
toast t-o-a-s-t
story worth is really the perfect thing
for the queue because you can stay
connected with your family and like have
fun activities
virtually and i just think it's
everything of the sort
and by the way we only allow sponsors
that are considered everything of the
sort according to you know the stock
market
only okay first story this is really the
big story of the day
ashley benson kisses g-eazy during an la
outing following her split from cara
delevingne
ashley benson is spending some time with
g-eazy the pretty little irish star and
the rapper
were spotted out and about in l.a on
wednesday the two were seen riding in a
car together as they picked up
food from the apple pan at one point
during the outing benson
was leaning over from behind the wheel
and kissed g-eazy who was sitting in the
passenger seat
a video of the kiss has also been
circulating on social media
a source previously told people that
benson has been hanging out with the
uh hit maker but it just but quote it
feels like
just a fling for now she's getting over
the breakup
i have something extremely controversial
to say
two things actually one i don't care
like truly i don't care i cared about
ashley benson when she was part of cara
television but now she's getting some
loser like whatever i can't be bothered
by it
and not that i want anyone to ever get
backlash but like
very thank you thank you thank you thank
you
ashley benson ashley benson was
literally quarantined like a month ago
in a house with a bunch of celebrities
now she's driving around with someone
else it's like
she's obviously not taking quarantine
seriously and i don't care everyone
could do what they want
but it's like i go see you for one
minute and i get cancelled like where is
the
outrage i literally lives in l.a she
lives in l.a
it's literally the same as new york i
[ __ ]
can't like she was in a different
relationship at the beginning of
quarantine so she obviously had to be
like
meeting up with someone that she's not
quarantined with to get into a new
relationship
i personally do not give two shits how
she wants to social distance and spend
her time but if everybody wants to come
for us all the time i need the same
exact standards
to be applied to everyone else i can't
[ __ ] take it anymore
and we're not even famous like we are
not we are nobodies like no
date every time i keep seeing these
stories like i i can't i can't stress
enough like how much i don't care like
of course i want to flatten the curve
and of course i want chronovirus to end
but like
i don't i'm just not the type of person
who's gonna like comfort someone else
because they made a decision that they
thought was right like
i'm sure ashley benson is taking the
proper precautions and i trust you to
know that she's not
going around licking people's faces like
i don't care but it's like
i cannot believe the level that like our
small family
dinner got to and it's like there are
celebrities every day being paparazzi
like here they're around car
[ __ ] kendall jenner and her boyfriend
drove to arizona like in a convertible
like
where is the outrage i can't like we
just send each other
other people who did the same exact
thing as we did or or worse bloggers who
are moving now
to different houses while they're in
california staying in new places
um we saw like the vanderpump rules
literally the day after
uh we had zak's gathering uh the
vanderpump roles kids like all
a few of them drove up to palm springs
to celebrate sheena's birthday and
they're like grinding on each other not
social distancing
where's the outrage some blogger had
like a birthday party for her kid with
like
literally balloons galore like as if
we're not in quarantine at all and i
just i didn't hear a
peep no no it's insane and it's like
i i was ready for like after we got hit
i'm like
oh these bloggers they're videoing their
kids birthday party like they're gonna
get killed what are they doing take
those down
not a peep not a peep
so you know what this teaches me it's
that i am the most famous person
in the world everyone pre-order my
comedy special
that's the moral of the story i just i
really i just can't believe it like the
standard that we're held to
and the way we were made to feel like
such coronavirus deniers when we were
literally going into week 10 of
quarantine and we chose
i just i can't go over like the facts
again
um i i just can't and i and i can't
believe
that like celebrity stories are popping
up like this about new relationships
isn't it cute and it's like no no it's
actually so cute but i just
need to make sure that the people who
came so hard and fast for us
are reading the same people magazine
story that i'm reading trolls i have
more content for you i have more people
whose addresses you should publish
online i have all the information for
you come follow me
oh my god i'm making it's making me so
mad like it's making my blood boil
margot keeps dming me like blogger
stories of bloggers who are like taking
like
staycations to like different houses or
hotels like in california and new york
and i'm like i can't stress enough like
i don't care like of course i i
genuinely
i believe verona rest i'm not a denier i
want it to end and i want everyone to do
what they can
but at the end of the day like this is a
free country and if someone feels like
it's okay to take a staycation like
that's their business that's none of my
business um
right and like we've been now in
quarantine for nine weeks and if you
want to take a staycation like i don't
see that there's anything wrong with
that whatsoever but i keep thinking
about it like if we were able to
get a house say in the hamptons or long
island or upstate and like
we all like our whole family went and
quarantined together there
no i know in my brain and my soul
there's absolutely nothing wrong with
that but like
we would be walking on eggshells like no
we would
we would get sponsors dropped we would
get like gigs canceled like i
like we would be it would be like
another version of trying to cancel us
because that's just what happens like
we've somehow become these people and
i'm not entirely sure how
but um it's that i just can't help but
like get so
outraged and it's not for the reasons
that when i think like i'm not outraged
that she's not quarantined because i'm
sure she's taking proper precautions
like
i'm just outraged like i'm not even
considered a famous person and it's like
i am like vilified we are vilified
for doing something that everyone is
[ __ ] doing and that like when you use
common sense there's absolutely nothing
wrong with considering none of us are
experiencing symptoms and we've all been
quarantined
for nine weeks like everyone is now just
like operating out of fear and outrage
and it's crazy yeah
so i'm so glad you had the same reaction
to this because like do i give a shred
of a [ __ ] who actually been since dating
or who g-eazy is making out with you
couldn't pay me to care
but i'm like how did they get in the car
how did they get to each other she was
in a house the other week she was with
this person then they broke up so it's
like there's a lot of movement
there's a lot of movement she must have
been walking past people on the street
and through crowded lobbies
yeah i can't
i can't i really can't oh my god okay
well
let's switch gears here because the next
story is like more fun
more fun kyle mclaughlin a.k.a
orsin from desperate housewives aka trey
from sex in the city was angry at his
sex in the city character
trey well so were we he was the [ __ ]
whoat
right but now here's what he thinks that
i try on paper trey appeared to be the
unicorn charlotte york
had been searching for so long on saxon
city a handsome wealthy cardiologist who
seemed doted on her but as fans of the
show know their marriage ended up being
a disaster
with an overbearing mother-in-law
problems in the bedroom and ultimately a
disregard for charlotte's desires to
become a mother
kyle mclaughlin who played trey on the
hvo series understands why a lot of fans
didn't like trey
and says he wasn't too fond of his
character either quote i was angry at
the character actually
what's this cardboard baby
when the couple couldn't conceive trey
infamously gifted charlotte with a
cardboard cutout of a baby and couldn't
understand why it upset her so much
quote i asked the writers and they said
oh it's funny so i went okay i'm not
sure i think so but okay
there was definitely a side to trade
that was a little oblivious to certain
things
and viewers had every right to be angry
with me if that's the case i was angry
with
me that is so funny i forgot about the
cardboard baby but to me that's not why
trey was the worst the trey was the
worst because
of course erectile dysfunction is not
ideal but he was just so unwilling to
like talk about it and be a man and like
try and find a solution he was just
acting like a child being like no no
and it's like that's not a husband so of
course every marriage has its problems
erectile dysfunction may be one of them
but if your partner's willing to like
try new things like charlotte taping
together the magazines like put her face
on the porn like
you have to try and he was just so
unwilling and so stubborn and like such
a mama's boy
that's why i didn't like it like the
cardboard baby thing i actually didn't
think was like that terrible
yeah he was just insensitive and also at
a certain point he was making charlotte
feel like it was
her when it was like something going on
with him and he just like was too
full of shame to like
take ownership yeah but like in an ideal
world like they
i mean her and harry are like otp
perfect forget for each other but for a
while it was like
that life with trey mcdougall on the
scottish sling like
that was the life charlotte like wanted
and you as a viewer wanted for her so it
was really disappointing when it didn't
work out but she got that classic six on
that breeze side and that's all yeah
he gave her that apartment which was
really so generous and
he brought her like this is i know it's
a show but like the relationship between
trey charlotte and then harry is like a
it's a message to women it's like
because if she didn't meet
trey they never would have gotten
divorced and she never would have met
her husband who was her divorce lawyer
harry and then it's like
that's life it's like you wish you
didn't date someone but they bring you
somewhere else and then you find someone
new
everything happens for a reason
everything
so i don't know why this story is like
being spoken about now but it's cool
um because he's like in a new show and
he was just doing press and he was
talking to h6 and they asked him about
trey and i just thought it was
something i mean he's he's one of my
like favorite actors like he's up there
because he's in all my favorite shows
and he's always just like rearing his
head like randomly and i'm surprised he
like wasn't an ugly betty you know
yeah oh my god everyone is popping up in
ugly betty literally everyone i was just
watching and who came through
uh [ __ ] i forget but like it's just
beyond star-studded um okay next story a
little cute news katy perry bears her
baby bump and more in the new music
video for daisies
so katy perry released a song today and
a music video where she's
bumping out um the song is so good i was
listening to it and i couldn't even
appreciate how good it was because
i was just trying to think of what song
it reminded me of it reminds me so much
of a song
i can't identify which one yet but i'll
get there um i think it might be an
ingrid
andres song like just the way have you
listened to the daisies yet
um it's it's really it's such a
beautiful song um but it just
it's just reminding me of something else
and so until i until i scratch that itch
i can't on
katy perry is just really she's doing
things you know she
she's like had a period of her career
where she was like an anne hathaway
where she couldn't do anything right she
wasn't
necessarily doing anything like evil or
bad she was just annoying the [ __ ] out
of everyone for no reason
um but now i'm like really loving her i
hope this song is good i mean
we were obsessed i mean the first
concert i ever went to was katy perry
and then we became so obsessed with
prism the album like she was such a
an influence for us and then her music
just kind of faded out um
i'm hoping she can get back to you know
the prism tour vibe because that was
this is this is more of a prism vibe um
she really lost us with like swish swish
and bon appetit and that whole
era was just chained to the rhythm which
like isn't a terrible song but like her
whole vibe then was just so
off was so off that song is only good if
you're in a soul cycle class and you're
all
changes because you're legit chained to
the rhythm in a class like that
what was the first concert you ever went
to john mayer
at jones beach
um with some camp counselors and olivia
oh that's cute yeah the counselors took
us we were the campers
the first concert i went to was um katy
perry at irving plaza with my friend
alex brazell who i've spoken about on
this podcast like more times than i care
to admit
and i think she listens to the podcast
like what up alex miss you you had never
been to a concert before we moved to the
city
no so i was in the eighth grade me and
alex i was in a new school we really
bonded over our love of katy perry and
we were allowed to go alone which is
like such a big deal
that's like such a crazy place to go
alone yeah but
and this was like when katy perry was
like on the warp tour she was more of
like an emo
star than she was a pop star like yeah
her vibe was kind of dark
um yeah i kissed a girl oh yeah that was
your vibe too
that was like so my vibe i was like so
emo and i just remember we like
where's ga like it was so messy like i
couldn't believe i was just an eighth
grader at a ga concert
and we were like right in front and i
had the best time and like i really felt
connected to her ever since
but she there was a few periods of time
like a few years where she was just
constantly letting me down
yeah but i think that she's in a new
phase of her life and
i look forward to to seeing what she
does yeah you know how they say like
celebrities or famous people get stunted
at the age that they became famous at
i feel like for a while like katy perry
whether it was just like trying to keep
up with her image or like the younger
pop stars i just felt like she was doing
things like not
because she thought it was what she
wanted to do was just because she
thought it was what she had to do to
like keep up and like be crazy and funny
and like
i don't know i'm now i feel like she's
pregnant her like priorities are
are set straight and she's just like
being a mom being a woman being
everything of the sort
yeah but she actually got famous like
relative to other
singers and celebrities she got famous
like late or for a singer
yeah but her whole vibe was like kitty
cat kitty purry you know like it was so
silly
yeah that's true her hollywood story is
actually i remember when it was on it
was asking hudson
yeah kate hudson it was actually such a
very interesting she grew up in like a
very religious family and she tried to
become like a christian singer because
that's what her parents wanted her to do
um and then when she decided to become a
pop star and like couchsurf you know
through la her parents
weren't entirely happy with her but in
the end they obviously supported her
love a happy ending
okay ready for our next story
mary kate olson loses the bid for
emergency divorce during coronavirus
court closures
mary kate olsen's emergency petition
sinking into seeking a divorce from
pierre
olivier sarkozy despite coronavirus
court closures
won't go forward after a manhattan judge
ruled that it wasn't an essential matter
manhattan supreme court justice michael
katz made the ruling thursday putting a
hall to olson's case
new york court spokesman lucien chalfin
confirmed
olson filed the case wednesday claiming
that her 50 year old banker hubby was
trying to kick her out of their
apartment by next monday
forcing her to try to look for a new
home during the chronovirus crisis
the actress had attempted to divorce
sarkozy um on april 17th but was blocked
by the courts which have been closed to
all
new non-emergency cases since late march
we didn't get a mary kate didn't get a
win very sad this [ __ ] sucks this is
what we were talking about a few weeks
ago like getting divorced and
quarantined like
you're stuck with this person that you
obviously now hate
he's trying to take her apartment away
from her like there needs to be a better
way and also like she's a celebrity i'm
sure she has like
connections and friends and resources
but like what about everyday people
right it's like i'm not necessarily
going to shed a tear over mary kate and
ashley who has the means to like shell
just rent a lot like
a fancy apartment in a fancy building
but it harkens like an actual issue of
people who have like shared finances
live in the same house are getting
divorced it might be like a scary or
abusive situation like you just can't
get out
yeah there needs to be a better way oh
you know what i saw this um refinery 29
um like interview video they did with
melissa benoist from glee
from nico from uh supergirl allegedly
but she's really from glee
and she remember she released that video
a while ago about um the toxic
relationship she was
in and she was kind of like trapped in
for all these years um
and then they did an interview with her
and they were splicing between the
interview and the video
and i just i didn't like her and glee
like she was my least favorite character
but i just like stan melissa but why
it's like marnie not so much but
stan melissa bonoy it's like she's so
well spoken and i just like i got
chills watching this whole video like
just explaining how like
what it's like to be in that type of
relationship and like all the lies you
create
and you're like lying for other people
and she like really documented some like
more details of the abuse and it's
horrifying and i think we assume that
it's
blake jenner from glee right yeah
they got married yeah that's been um
the assumption is that not a confirmed
thing
i'm not sure but like i think we
we know but right we know what we don't
know
yeah anyways thank you for sharing that
everyone should go watch that
we okay
fifth and final story a little broadway
news
that's very appropriate that it's
broadway news because it's brought to
you
by a sponsor that really adds a little
pep to our step it makes us want to sing
a particular song
embark that he hit it jacket
okay he just took a dna test
turns out he's a hundred percent rush it
even when he's fleeing countries yeah
he's got health problems that's the
puppy in him
bling bling then he solves him that's a
doctor and he could have had a bad tigs
non-committal helped you with your
welfare
just a little he used to hold you down
but now he's holding you back
and that's the sound of his wolfy
mislead in the pack
that takes great tilly gotta be great
he's damn smooth do this one again
sorry theo he wants to kill me thank you
jackie for that wonderful introduction
in today's
episode sponsor
give me a minute i'm very out of breath
it's okay
take your time embark that
is the dog dna test kit we all need
next time at the end yeah please i'm
like not well running and holding him
i'm so sorry
have you ever been in a situation where
you're walking with your dog and someone
stops you how cute what kind of dog is
that
you don't know you're not alone because
every year millions of dogs are rescued
from shelters
and that means there's a lot we don't
know about them but you can finally know
your dog with an embark
breed and health test whether you have a
brand new puppy or an old friend
the embark breed and health test is the
key to unlocking your dog's
unique mix and genetically informed
health needs so you can help your pup
live the longest and happiest life
the process of getting an embark kit is
so easy they just like literally send
you a box it has a q-tip well not a
q-tip like a medical grade
thing swab and a pre-paid label put the
swab in theo's cheeks
up right down left put it back in the
box with the prepaid label send it out
and then like two weeks later i got a
text message and it was like
theo's dna test kit is here and it was
fascinating actually but theo's a
purebred so like he wasn't that
interesting but
if you have a rescue or a mix i don't
think the
uh yeah or a mix dog with different
breeds it's actually really really
fascinating and then you can know more
about like how to keep them healthy
things that they're
predisposed to like medical conditions
theo's breed is actually predisposed to
heart conditions so
his weight is very important that's why
he's on a strict diet yeah
you find out what level of wolfyness
your pup possesses
theo is three percent wolfiness um which
is pretty low but
something the embark dog dna test kit is
the most comprehensive kit on the market
looking at over 250 breeds and 175
genetic health conditions to help you
best care for your pup
it's the only research grade dog dna
test kit on the market and it's more
than twice as precise as any other dog
dna test kit
this is because their scientists look at
over 200 000 genetic markers and can
make scientific discoveries
that help all dogs live longer healthier
lives
did you you might not know that over 50
of dogs are either at risk or a carrier
of a genetic disease
so their panel of tests creates a screen
for over 175 of those genetic diseases
which can be presented in many breeds
whether it's mixed or pure
it's the best in class dog dna test and
the number one highest rated by
customers because it's developed by phds
and veterinarians for your dog
it's the most accurate breed
identification on the market and it's
more than twice as precise as the
competitors
you can get to know your dog's breed and
learn how to best care
for your pup love it
if you if you have a dog and you care
about him which i'm sure you do
embark has an exclusive offer just for
our listeners go to embark vet dot com
use the promo code toast to save 15 off
your dog breed and health kit
visit embark bet e-m-b-a-r-k
v-e-t dot com and use the promo code
toast to save 15
off today that's embark that dot com and
the promo code is toast thank you embark
love it it's also a great gift for
someone especially doggie and sneakers
yes okay see the final story a little
broadway news
frozen officially concludes its broadway
run
the broadway production of frozen will
not reopen as a result of the
industry-wide shutdown and resulting
economic fallout
the production's final performance was
wednesday evening march 11th having
played 825 performances
and 26 previews guest holding tickets
for frozen who purchased via
ticketmaster will be refunded
automatically within 30 days
um that's really sad i kind of wanted to
see that
no it's just shocking i felt like of
course every show has its run but
certain shows become like like lion king
is it's a
family classic i really felt like frozen
was gonna be one of those shows that's
just on forever
yeah i think they really just couldn't
withstand this economic turmoil
and disney has uh two other shows on
broadway lion king and aladdin
and i think frozen is probably like
since it's the newest one it just
doesn't have the chops to
survive um this pandemic
yeah i'm shocked that it
outlasted i mean that it didn't outlast
aladdin because aladdin is obviously
older and it's a
great show but kids like frozen is a was
a cultural reset like it was like barney
for us like
kids and adults around the world are
just [ __ ] obsessed with it so i just
really thought it was going to be one of
those like
lifelong broadway hits but i guess not
yeah i guess i mean it might have been
in a different time you know
right not in the sad times
that's very sad speaking of sad i would
love to
recap the absolute dumpster fire trash
that was last night's episode of real
housewives of new york
let's do it can i just tell you how you
know we're in a bad season filled with
women who are not what i aspire to be
like they were just so like
focused and impressed and like even made
it a point to mention how fancy like the
sprinter man was
i missed that part like when they went
to the man luanne was like
isn't this fabulous and it's like this
is standard housewives like every every
city beverly hills when they atlanta
when they go on a trip like they get a
fancy stretch limo or a fancy like van
and it's like they were just impressed
by that and it's because none of the
women
the show and i can't stress this enough
the problem with this season is that
this is supposed to be an
aspirational show it's about a certain
level
of woman in new york or women in beverly
hills that is supposed to be
luxurious and whether it's through their
apartments the things that they say the
trips they take like it's just not
giving me that vibe
that's always like the cherry on top of
housewives is you know the level of
glamour and some
uh franchises like don't have it and
it's not that important like
i don't think that that's what's wrong
with this season like the personalities
of the women are what's wrong like
first and foremost dorinda the meanest
woman
i've ever seen last night like talking
to tinsley as if she is
the [ __ ] on her shoe like so [ __ ]
rude it's uncomfortable to watch it is
not enjoyable
like watching her try and come up with
new one-liners to like i don't know go
viral
by being a mean person it's just it's
not enjoyable and then of course like
you want to root for tinsley but like
her comebacks just [ __ ] suck
and she's like wailing and just being
running away
and it's just like she you can't root
for her because
she's not like a real contender
and the whole and like honestly ramona's
the one making the most sense in her
interviews
and it's just like what has this world
come to then the whole episode was just
a [ __ ] mess like what was going on
between the written the conversation
with dorinda luanne all talking about
like
burying husbands and losing husbands
like i understand that that is so
traumatic but it seems like every single
meal and conversation and drinking event
devolves into that and it's like okay um
we weren't like watching you guys seven
years ago i don't know these people that
you're talking about like i don't know
jp morgan's grandson like
right are you referring to i just i feel
like
i'm i just i'm uninvested and if we did
i've said this before
like truly if we did not do this show i
would have stopped watching the season i
think leah is a great addition but like
she can only do so much to save the show
um luanne judging leah's apartment when
her apartment is
a two-bedroom apartment in new york city
it's the same one that ramone is living
in
sonia dorinda like excuse me she has the
nerve
to comment on someone else's apartment
when last season she had to move out of
tom's
penthouse alleged which i heard wasn't
even on the top floor and moved to that
sad rental on the upper west side
and by the way where is luan even living
right
now unclear in her cottage in sag harbor
please these women are such
full so full of [ __ ] so full of [ __ ]
like
i i just
i did not enjoy myself it took me two
hours to get through the episode they
were just
every time i pressed play i was like
eyes rolling to the back of my head
it's just it's not it and i really think
that dorinda
is like spoiling the group camaraderie
because she's so negative and so mean
and no one will stick up to her
to me the most egregious part of the
episode was watching sonia and leah pee
in that man's corn field like i actually
had a pin in my stomach like
this local guy business owner let these
like trash bags into their [ __ ]
beautiful farm and they take a piss on
his [ __ ] corn are you kidding
yeah that was gross but uh
like does he crop all that does he
harvest all that corn
i don't care they don't know whether he
does or doesn't
maybe it was really upsetting me yeah
that's really [ __ ] gross
i just want to really quickly just go
back to the whole like luxury money
thing because
while i hear what you're saying not
every franchise has
like that factor but i feel like every
franchise
has a level of wealth
for the city do you know what i mean
it's like most of the houses even though
i know like some of the finances of some
of the jersey women are a little murky
they all live in big houses and they all
drive range rovers you know what he
means true
houses are really nice atlanta they live
in huge
literally palaces everyone candy like
everyone has a huge house
even kenya more more matters like a
little weird but it's still a [ __ ]
nice house like i like everyone's
yeah no and that uh that video i'll
never forget of her running out of her
house with a gun to chase off some
robber like she was being so funny like
that house is iconic like and they're
nice houses like
there's a level even if a lot of it is a
facade which i totally agree that it is
like some of the houses are rented the
cars are leased like
i totally get it but there's none of
that they're not even trying to fake it
anymore in new york and that's what's
upsetting
yeah and also this style is
there's not one stylish
woman and like new york is supposed to
be the epicenter of style maybe it's
just like a reflection of how new york
the city itself has gone down the two
like even new york fashion week is not
really a thing anymore
um and so maybe it's just a reflection
of the city
that's possible but but you're right
especially about the style it's like do
i think everything that the real
housewives of dallas wears
is stunning no but it's really like a
reflection of dallas society and dallas
culture and dallas style
and their you know they all have nice
houses and they all have nice cars like
i refuse to accept anything less i'm
sorry
that's like the one bar the one
requirement for being a real housewife
in new york is being a woman and having
some money and these women just don't
collectively like they don't have enough
they collectively don't even match what
like one beverly hills housewife has do
you know what i mean
yeah and something that was just
frustrating me like on a logistics level
was tinsley carrying a
major like a work tote bag like the
louis vuitton on the go
that you have um she was wearing it to
like a winery
and i just don't know and it looked like
the bag was kind of empty so like what
did
she needed such a big bag for and just
like i just didn't understand why she
couldn't go with
some sort of smaller actually that would
the winery would have been the perfect
situation for a crossbody
oh god yeah um if you were asked to be
on real housewives of new york like we
live in new york and we're both married
like we would say yeah right
i think so after some consideration
yeah yeah i just putting it out there
into the universe
yeah that's part of the reason i got
married in the first place just so i
could be like a contender even though
none of the women are married
right oh and i guess the big news of the
day was that dorinda and john broke up
oh don't care yeah me either
that's our weekend sorry to be you know
what's so funny is like i was on a zoom
with
my like high school friends and we were
talking about stuff and my friend anna
like we have
me and my high school friends have been
watching bravo since like before it was
appropriate like we are die hard bravo
fans
and on was like can you believe the
season of new york house i'm like i know
it's such a piece of [ __ ] she was are
you kidding me it's incredible i'm like
what i literally couldn't believe that
she said that we could have like such
different opinions so i don't know what
we're saying
is necessarily like a popular opinion
i'm sure people are going to tell us
but i couldn't believe that she said
that interesting
yeah well i'm not enjoying it so
especially when it's put on
juxtaposed with real houses beverly
hills they should really put it on the
same
season as real housewives of orange
county and maybe you'll get a fair shake
they should just switch the days the
fact would be to go from wednesday
beverly hills glamour to thursday new
york trash like it's such a downhill
spiral like
we should just switch them we work up to
the glamour of beverly hills
yeah i agree okay i'm officially ready
for the weekend to start so if it's okay
with you i spoke to her she said that's
all she wrote and i'm gonna wrap the
[ __ ] up
she that's what she had said thank you
guys so much for listening to the
morning shows monday morning show where
we go live monday friday 10 30am time on
youtube if you're watching us on youtube
please feel free to subscribe and give
this video a thumbs up
we're also available on the podcast and
we're podcasting found so much spotify
institute public video i already have
spots all the places where we listen
podcasts find out some morning shows
live stream you better be
time that's where we are please don't
forget to pre-order my comedy special
available on itunes the link is
available on my bio and instagram
girl with no no what's it called claudia
ashrae disgrace queen
girl with no job bye guys love you
oh are you going to show us your curl
there she is curl with no job
bye